quant aux excuses aux trouve aujourd'hui
on se trouve sur duty calls de calme
avant la tempête c'est parti si tu te
parle d'un call of duty qui est sorti ya
plusieurs années et qui a accompagné la
sortie du jeu bulletstorm
c'est parti oh mon dieu dit bien ce nom
onley s'étayait ce nom aux prostitué e s
c'est pas mal j'aime bien ce genre de
bab au coeur d'enjeux
ok merci général à vos ordres
ok la porte est ouverte toute attention
il va falloir vraiment être efficace là
tout le monde compte sur nous c'est
parti on y va à temps ces camerounais
qui se fait dans des colloques pour la
le lanceur au bon dieu
buts avait marre voilà rogers
je suis désolé bon ok on continue on
échoue novillo n'est tranché il ya des
gens qui meurent il faut les aider il
faut laisser courir tous à temps c'est
au nord au génial ok je suis prêt quoi
pour une [ __ ] c'est pas ennuyant quand
je te bute ok voilà fait moins le malin
dans tes fougères bâtard hockey au côté
du oui c'est vrai
allez tu meurs à revoir on n'arrête pas
de rancoeur [ __ ] on est bon mais bon
je pense que c'est possible de rater de
juin attention ce qui amène ici on dit
on arrive dans la base entend récupérer
des branches mais guy hoquet droit la
broche pourra construire la cabane on
est bon on vendu à couvert ok c'est
parti oh mon dieu ce haricot schumi
pourquoi à je sais vous êtes pour la
brancher le met un coup sec sur la nuque
d'où l'importance de cette vision de
temps à cinématique
oui c'est parti au dos le motion frère
décédé
la réponse est oui oh oh je me suis dit
c'est génial de parodier [ __ ] c'est
d'élire la 2de slow motion évoqué dans
les jeux c'est super cher continue à
découvrir ajoute 18 moko oran club
attention à qui sorti tel un lapin de
stars bien problèmes mondiaux comme ou
de quels réflexes hors du commun aux
[ __ ] là les grandes zones comme ça
j'aime pas du tout aux thématiques
attention était hollywoodien c'est
génial c'est trop marrant ce qu'ils ont
trouvé comme vague quoi le vieux mec en
parachute c'est vrai que mes 20 ans
tomber tu veux pas que tu es tranquille
en l'air [ __ ] au débat là je me dis a
manqué deux balles
on vient d'amasser 500 pages de truc nul
qu'il faut lire apparemment ok au palais
dans un regard attention c'est parti
rendez-nous commissaire borg
do you give me some en terrasse c'est
vrai que des fois tu les kovac avait
créé un bravo j'ai tellement gentil
bravo non mais c'est un boisé méchant
gentil quand même on va pas se mentir à
la fameuse pub pour bulletstorm qui suit
jeu ok bah je préférais duty calls a
présentement des parodies on se retrouve
maintenant sur coup hills cop simulator
parce que naples et ce n'est pas terminé
soldats ces partis star sujet sortie à
un milliard d'années voilà joue que
maintenant mais ça fait plaisir je
voulais absolument le faire tous les 52
cents et 420 qu'il tue sera récompensé
par un kit strict au hockey c'est parti
oh mon dieu attend c'est ça le giec pour
de vrai on en est là quoi il faut aller
à des mecs qui viennent ok mais que
c'est grave ce ski mondiaux je me suis
plus que tu aies pu tâter résume une
attrition tonnerre tout ce qui est
mauvais de façon à les voler je suis
pris à bord de bâtard je suis désolé
rage pas petit enfant olala ou écrire
mon nom est un squeeze et s'il vous
plaît j'ai pas la grosse tête sinon ça
va on a la meilleure cote à ga iru joie
bientôt la tribu talité pour faire des
grosses mais à la base de ce qu'ils j'ai
les yeux qui piquent ce qu'est ce qui
t'as plus désuète gendarmerie que
l'épilepsie l'album de la bande son du
jeu est disponible soit judicieux si ça
peut vous faire plaisir j'avais plus à
part les nac aistrika package
qu'est-ce qu'on a des avions mais la vie
aux mondiaux c'est tout claquer on dira
mail qui attaquent les gens que les
enfants eurent on se croirait dans la
cour de récréation d'une école primaire
oh [ __ ] car package c'est parti qu'est
ce qu'on a c'est quoi ça
c'est croire face à face à leeds watts
sa part sur une brosse à dents sur toi
ok on a tiré sur la planète c'est la
meilleure depuis stoppeur du groupe qui
sont la lutte
ce jeu est à la fois cool et
insupportable seront décrites eu le cri
cannabis mon blog
merci ce nouveau pack offert un [ __ ]
bad trip c'est partie de ce qu'ils
veulent chez le petit enfant chute au le
magasin
qu'est ce que c'est ces quartiers qui se
passe comme ça ces outils aux arts le
cas il ya un max déclare mike c'est fait
il va se ressemblent il a débuté sous ça
ils sont juste tous bords ok c'était
naze au large aussi un poids de cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas là mais ça vous a
plu j'avais absolument envie de jouer à
ces deux petits jeux parodique du dico
j'ai découvert ce matin
eh oui si obtus et adore j'ai vu il ya
des années j'avais jamais eu ce plaisir
cette sensation d'être fort sur call of
duty allons surtout de procéder au
versement regardez ce que ça vous a plu
portez vous bien tu as tout en bessin